[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones Season 8 video
about how Varys is connected to the
Tower of joy Rhaegar Targaryen Lyanna
Stark in Jon Snow there's a new round of
the book giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so important idea
Varys is partially responsible for some
of the events that led to Robert's
rebellion it wasn't just any one thing
that led the Kingdom to war against the
Mad King there were several critical
moments on the path and Varys is
responsible for one of the biggest ones
really early on and it involves a secret
plan to sabotage Rhaegar Targaryen they
were actually a couple scenes during
season 7 where Daenerys took him to task
for his culpability in some of these
events saying don't you ever cross me or
I'll burn you like I burn everyone else
that I don't like there's also some
evidence to suggest that he's one of the
few characters who has an idea for Jon
Snow's true mother and father Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark but might
just not have every last piece of
information to put everything into
context so important backstory Varys was
the master of whispers for Robert
Baratheon but the more important thing
that the show doesn't remind you of very
often is that he was also the master of
whispers for the Mad King for the larger
part of his later years when he got
full-blown crazy before that Varys grew
up on the streets of volantis as a slave
initially to the sorcerer the infamous
sorcerer that he tells the story about
through my bits on the fire in a voice
called out from the flames same sorcerer
that wound up in the box that he showed
to Tyrion much to his chagrin oh my god
what's going on here after that he
escaped to the streets and survived as a
pickpocket where he met Illyrio and they
scammed their way into a small Empire so
Illyria grew very rich in Varys also
used that opportunity to create the
prototype for his network of little
birds that at the time while they were
in the East he called his little mice so
the little birds network is something
that came about when he came to Westeros
his information network was so good in
the East that word of his talents
reached the Mad King who by this time
had descended into full-blown paranoia
he officially named Varys master of
whispers right after he lost his most
trusted advisor on the small Council to
a freak accident that was Steffon
Baratheon the father of Stannis Renly in
Robert Baratheon how much
ironic then are the events of Robert's
rebellion given that Steffon Baratheon
was one of his closest advisors
Steffon Baratheon had been on a mission
to the east to find a bride for Rhaegar
Targaryen only found patch faced the
fool in their boat sank within sight of
storm's end on the return voyage in a
freak storm so the Mad King losing the
only powerful person close to him that
he trusted grew even more paranoid and
needed varus's little mice network of
information that was in 278 AC about
four years before the official start of
Robert's rebellion doesn't seem like it
took long to light that match so Varys
grew his network of Street orphan spies
in the Westerosi little birds Network it
worked perfectly the Mad King loved all
the information that Varys was giving
him little did he know that secretly
Varys did not serve him in the truest of
sense he considered himself a servant of
the realm a man for the good of the
people and still remembered the voice
from the flames and knew that the realm
needed a strong leader because something
terrible was coming so Varys made a
series of calculated decisions for what
he felt like was the good of the realm
at that time sabotage some really good
characters as we saw play out in present
day when he refused to speak up for Ned
Stark about the truth of Joffrey being
jaime and cersei son he also led a lot
of really bad things happen that would
eventually lead to Robert's rebellion or
sort of helped things along the way that
would lead to that rebellion one of the
biggest things early on tying this back
to Rhaegar Targaryen Jon Snow and Lyanna
Stark is that really early on Varys
learned of Rhaegar Targaryen secret plot
to depose his father the Mad King so the
Mad King was right not to trust Rhaegar
because he had felt like his son was
plotting against him this whole time
Rhaegar secretly organized the tourney
at Harrenhal the famous turning our
infamous depending on how you think
about it with the knight of the Laughing
tree and several other really big things
happen there but the whole idea was to
finance attorney secretly with the purse
large enough that the prize would entice
all the great Lords of the realm to come
to the tourney at the time nobody knew
who was putting the gold up for the
tournament they assumed that it was
Tywin Lannister because Lannister gold
mines he'd be one of the few people that
had that much money on hand but secretly
Rhaegar was using this as a pretense to
gather all the greatest Lords of the
realm to call a secret Great Council and
depose his father the Mad King and he
would just do it under the guise of this
tourney like oh that's why
here we're not here to talk about
usurping the throne so because at that
time the Mad King had grown so paranoid
of everyone around him plotting against
him that all Bears had to do was whisper
about the tourney in his ear your son
will be there with all the most powerful
Lords in the realm without even having
to connect the dots for him so
surprising everyone the Mad King left
King's Landing to show up at the
tournament so that he could keep an eye
on Rhaegar and the Lords at the time he
had gone full-blown Howard Hughes so it
was a big surprise that he would leave
the red keep for any reason so it was a
big deal that he showed up at the
tourney but you also remember there are
several other really big events that
happen at the tourney of Harrenhal it's
where a teenage Jaime Lannister was
officially inducted into the Kingsguard
the Mad King did that just despite Tywin
Lannister who he was most afraid of even
though at the time Tywin wasn't trying
to usurp the Iron Throne or anything
like that the mad Kings feud with Tywin
Lannister is a whole other video they
have a very very deep history together
and largely it's the mad Kings madness
to blame for their falling out the
tourney at Harrenhal is also where we
see the famous knight of the Laughing
tree which most evidence points towards
us secretly being Lyanna stark and even
though we don't officially have a
timeline of when Rhaegar really fell in
love with Lyanna stark and hatched their
plan to run away together I would say he
probably discovered that she was the
knight of the Laughing tree at the
tournament and that's one of the events
that sealed the deal for him like oh now
I really love this girl it's pretty
clear that by the end of that tournament
something was going on between the two
of them because he won the joust and
rode past his wife to crowned Liana with
the blue roses everyone was there it was
a very public event all the Lords were
scandalized everyone was shocked oh my
god what's going on here why is he
riding past his wife the princess Elia
to do this so there's a whole other
video that I could do about the events
surrounding the knight of the Laughing
tree is a really fascinating story so
maybe I'll do a separate bonus video
when we get closer to the season 8
premiere but obviously Varys was
successful and thwarting regards planned
to get rid of the Mad King with his
secret Great Council so they weren't
able to do that versus reason for doing
that as he explains the last couple of
seasons he's been with Daenerys and
Tyrion is that he felt like the other
options that were available for
leadership of the realm of the time were
not good enough he didn't have a lot of
information about the White Walkers at
the time the night
King the red God but he knew something
terrible was coming and felt like the
other candidates for the throne just
were not the right people for the job
but since varys's little birds Network
had all their eyes on the big players in
and around Robert's rebellion it's
pretty easy to assume that he had an
idea for what Rhaegar was doing when he
ran off in secret to marry Lyanna stark
one really good reason why he would not
tell the Mad King or anyone else about
this and just allow Rhaegar to sort of
get away with Lyanna Stark is that he
want Rhaegar sidelined he didn't want
him on the throne and when they ran off
together Rhaegar was effectively
abandoning his bid for the Iron Throne
which would have been an acceptable
outcome for Varys now he didn't want
Rhaegar dead or anything like that but
he didn't want him on the throne either
so even if Varys didn't know at the time
that Rhaegar and Lyanna had secretly Wed
legitimately and he had annulled his
marriage to Elia Martell he probably had
enough information about the events
surrounding Rhaegar and Lyanna zhh
disappearance in the timing of Ned
Stark's return with a mystery baby - at
least be suspicious about the truth of
Jon Snow's parentage but because no heir
has surfaced in the last 16 to 17 years
and he was spending most of his time
looking for a better candidate because
Daenerys was still a very young girl and
hadn't surfaced at that time he was just
trying to keep tabs on everyone and keep
the round balanced until a better
candidate came along so that's probably
why he didn't dig too deep into Jon
Snow's true origin that's why I think
that he's to be a little surprised when
everyone may or may not learn the truth
of events but he wouldn't be quite as
surprised about Jon Snow's parentage as
everyone else
like I had my thoughts about Rhaegar and
Lyanna possibly having a child but
didn't pay them any mind at the time and
if you're wondering why Varys his
network of little birds was so good and
he had information on everyone in the
realm why then did he bail on King's
Landing at the end of season four this
is because he felt like there was too
much evidence tying him to Tyrians
escape Tywin's death and then
subsequently Joffrey's death by
association
everyone knew he was close to Tyrion so
he just felt like they would connect the
dots and say Varys is responsible for
all this so that's why he preemptively
bailed and then when they get to the
east he explains his grand plan to
Tyrion for the better candidate so by
that time he had been watching Daenerys
his campaigns in the east and in Mereen
and felt like she was the better person
to lead the realm and prepare it for the
dangers that were to come
if you sat on the Iron Throne would you
spread misery throughout the land I will
never sit on the Iron Throne
now you aren't the Seven Kingdoms need
someone stronger than Tommen but gentler
than Stannis a monarch who can
intimidate the High Lords and inspire
the people the ruler loved by millions
with a powerful army and the right
family name the funny thing in all that
is is that Varys because of his
culpability in the events that led to
Robert's rebellion is also responsible
for Daenerys growing up in exile which
see then in later seasons connected the
dots and took him to task for like you
double-crossed my father the Mad King
you were supposed to be serving him you
were supposed to be helping my brother
not trying to sabotage him if you
double-cross me I'll burn you like I
burn everyone that I don't like so let
me know in the comments do you think
that Varys would be suspicious of Jon
Snow's true heritage in the events
surrounding the Tower of joy thinking
that maybe Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen could have had a child
together Varys on the TV show kind of
seems like he's gotten a little bit
Dumber with the last couple of seasons
it's sort of a tyrion problem you
watched the first three or four seasons
when they're adapting George RR Martin's
book material directly in they're very
clever they're one step ahead of
everyone else but then the last couple
of seasons tyrion starts making all
kinds of mistakes his dialogue isn't
quite as witty and the same thing starts
to happen to Varys so it'll be
interesting to see what happens to them
during season eight but I will do a
death predictions video when we get a
little bit closer still waiting on
another Big Game of Thrones Season 8
trailer which supposedly we're going to
be getting in the next couple of weeks
but if I get any news about a trailer I
will totally post an update in a video
congratulations Jackie Campbell you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Game of Thrones video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details click here for
my new Game of Thrones Season 8 Iron
Throne teaser video and click here for
my new season 8 episode 1 teaser video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see
guys tonight